reject nation book of boba fett chapter five
it's a thick one it's a long one what are
we hoping for baby yoda yo grug we're hoping
a little den jordan's gonna show back up today
two grown creepy ass men talking
guys if you can go ahead use the force to
hit that like button that would be very much
appreciated also subscribe to get notified
when our next reaction for boba fett is up
as always full length watch along where you
sync up with the time code for book above
a feder over at our patreon page massive thank
you to all who have become superjects today
showing your support for the channel and checking
all the content we gotta offer there and as
always thanks to the boys of prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights and we must
continue our segment of things that we got
wrong or completely flew over our heads last
week and the only one that we really got wrong
was uh we couldn't quite remember the whole
thing with wookie and trend oceans their history
like i've seen clone wars and i i didn't remember
the episodes that explored this according
to some of the comments from last week but
yeah apparently there's a whole history of
enslaving them that they didn't even establish
in the one of the earlier episodes of this
show where they brought in the pelton yeah
yeah like a child wookie it looked like so
get ready correct us on whatever we get wrong
in this episode we'll bring it up next episode
thank you guys because that's what comment
boxes are for i'm watching a whole like 40
minute video and only commenting what we get
wrong you're helping out the channel
this on the same planet we're in the mandalorian
episode with uh
i think that's him
let's do this i'm here for kabab i'm here
to bring him in well if i see him i'll let
him know i see him right now
that's not me that doesn't even look like
me you're racist let's discuss our options
i can bring you in warm or i can bring you
in cold i can bring you in like a [ __ ]
and in two pieces
that's right i have the dark side back he's
like the ahsoka this season yeah
you all can help yourselves to whatever you
think you deserve from your former employer
just give us mandalorian season three you
know what we want it's the body like ah yes
do it that's a ship he upgraded to elysium
yes
i'd put that on ice if i were you
well with the background this is one of the
most beautiful one takes i've seen in a while
great use of sound design too
the hilt is of a quality of best car i have
never seen before it was forged over a thousand
years ago by the mandalore tar whistler i
have met jedi and you have completed your
quest then you may join our covert as we rebuild
this is the way this is the way this is the
way this is the damn way [ __ ] a andalorian
steel is meant for armor not weapons then
forge it into armor wow an honorable man had
our sect not been cloistered on the moon of
concordia we would have not survived the great
purge
we're gonna actually see inside yeah yeah
i bet we those are of mandalore strayed away
from the path eventually the imperial interlopers
destroyed all that we knew and loved in the
night of a thousand tears oh golly
it's like a nuclear air raid
how heroin
recap all the necessary information you would
have needed to watch the clone wars and star
wars troubles just
that is because you are fighting against the
blade you should be fighting against your
opponent the blade should be an extension
of you i am focused the blade says otherwise
maybe the dark saber belongs in someone else
oh [ __ ]
oh don't get knocked off i have loved it
come on buddy
whoa
come on
have you ever removed your helmet
i think once or twice no comment i have
then you are a mandalorian no more what i
beg you for your forgiveness oh according
to creed one may only be redeemed in the living
waters beneath the mines of mandalore but
the mines have all been destroyed this is
the way there's only like three of you come
on guys can i take the dark saber with me
they set us up for mandalorians
claim that status also win back mandalore
build a home for new waters to re-emerge from
it's not the
same green
creature
is it a womp it is a warm bread okay it's
not here maybe it ran oh jesus
jurassic park it's a very strong one
what an entrance you're good good holy crap
i knew i recognized that droid it's bd1 from
jedi fallen order oh man uh yeah yeah i should
have called that out of the moment i should
have
still haven't got that clear live-action look
never ever will where's your unlikely companion
i returned him to his own kind where the hell
would you do that where's the ship it's right
this way
now this is padre
and i know she doesn't look like much but
you got here a lot earlier than i expected
and and i didn't get a chance to finish i
mean clearly you can see i've got all the
parts right here it's a good ship and in a
few years it'll fly where did you get this
it's brand new well jawa new they give me
what i asked for in exchange i let them pick
through my dumpster can i meet them yeah sure
r5 see if the javas are still out back r5
lives on break free oh they're waiting for
that don't worry about the shape and size
just get the parts you want the specs you
need and i'm gonna make it work all right
i dated a chawa oh
that's okay i'm working on me right now just
go find the party
i just want one piece of concept art with
her in a java i thought i'd be so excited
for a prequel ship where does this panel go
thanks little guy oh buddy you want to thank
me now or you want to thank me later you get
me a razor crest you can have it right back
oh bantha diddle these are a lot harder to
come by than some plain old razor crest razor
crest
i feel like he utilizes the razor cross shape
the size of it i feel like it had a use for
everything on that ship yeah he uses the space
he's got to be able to take prisoners i got
it they said they crawled under a pike spice
runner and crimped it off while they were
refueling pike spices pikes do not mess around
ever since they've been moving spice to the
system everything's gone to hell everyone's
afraid of them and law enforcement won't even
go near them except one guy it fits
wake up the suns are up yes now they sobered
it out look at that stripped all that yellow
off oh not a gram of fat honor you know no
one's catching you in this thing they put
that thing together [ __ ] fast yeah like
an afternoon start her up really yeah start
her up sure it's really mine huh it's working
it's working oh no
awesome that's what i'm talking about give
me the top of the town
dang farrick
awesome she tracks like a rails feeder
that's a thumbnail finally
yeah go wave at that kid
mcclunky
you're also operating without a beacon i'm
gonna need you to run one for us who's this
cameo i think we can let him off with the
warning this time thank you officer i'll have
that taken care of one thing before you go
yes your voice is mighty familiar do you used
to fly a razor crest oh no i think you have
the wrong guy officer you mind answering a
few questions
attack of the clones that respect must legitimize
all past installments how was it wizard
an old friend of yours dropped by said she
was looking for you a friend of mine don't
worry i told her i didn't know where you were
then i locked her out and engaged the hangar
security system she tell you her name then
oh yeah there's a book of boba fett
hey is good what's the bounty no bounty we
need muscle boba fett he sure would appreciate
it tell him it's on the house awesome but
first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend
dallas
is
he has no clue he's got a clone worship that
ship's seen so much battle man yeah try to
remember wasn't there another like thing in
the mandalorian where he he also had like
one of anakin's he had a piece of attitude
pod racing yeah they wasn't yeah yeah he had
like a speeder made out of one of the racer
engines yeah yeah yeah it's just a vandalian
episode i know i thought it's gonna be like
the socas episode where it's like oh we're
just kicking it off with her here and then
we'll cut back and forth with his side she's
just like no we're just going to do a mandible
right episode pretty much this is a little
teaser for season three this is funny that
was crazy i like how they took this episode
to give us all the backstory that did not
give the freaking actual mandalorian show
when the dark stairs introduced when they
throw it all in here part of me is wondering
if this is all going to be a great big meanwhile
to fill in some holes so that season three
could be boba and mando teamed up it's like
let's explain bo katan bisla they didn't bring
us to being rent at all which i thought was
interesting but that's true it was just handed
off to her at the end there i really enjoyed
the last few episodes of bugaboo fed a lot
but there is something about like this is
it just feels like there's an injection of
momentum
and then the fact that we're actually traveling
through space at some point
a setting too with that big ring that like
we haven't even really seen before instead
of being in places that we have seen and that
are being fleshed out yeah yeah i don't recall
what that is if it's been in clone wars rebels
guys you can just uh feel free to you know
tell us in the comments we'll bring it up
next episode but yeah that was great that
was that was awesome so fun that was awesome
can't wait to see him in boba yeah man talk
it out be who be mono syllabic together do
you remember me i am and jaren i need your
help
uh let's shitty chat well that was a great
one the first episode of the mandalorian season
three is here with us today those quotes i
i think that's the first time we've seen a
womp rat in live action glory i'm pretty sure
that's the case right am i wrong about that
we've seen womp rat and other mediums of star
wars but i can't recall the time that's what
i've been always itching for is like i hope
we see a whomp brand in live action and we
finally hit that's my main takeaway he's like
nothing for fun
a new hope you know so i'm just like come
on man legendary let's see some damn womp
it only took 40 years to say um but if i'm
wrong about that just just tell me and i'm
just not remembering that correctly but no
this was this was a great episode this was
this was wonderful so much more than i i wasn't
expecting just a full blown let's just make
it a mando focused episode getting the return
of dinjar and catching up there with so much
um you know paz vizsla the armor and yeah
as they like go through the whole back story
of so much um to unpack there i love the training
sequence between the armor and mando because
uh in in rebels when sabine wren has the dark
saber she's training with kanan and kanan
is jedi so she's like learning from a jedi
directly and so that scene was making me think
of that but there's a lot of different context
around it because you know as as much as the
armor respects the ways of the force she herself
is not a jedi and you know they're fighting
styles and their their belief systems there's
a lot of difference and all the differences
there so you're getting a different type of
training sequence but there's still motifs
about it that make make one hearken back to
those moments and i believe dave filoni was
involved with ruppel i think that was his
show too i think so he's like everything animated
star wars has his hand on something anything
like monumental tv assistant yeah yeah so
uh to be to be harkening back to that of course
i thought was just wonderful to behold and
um yeah uh with you know past vizila wanting
it it's like if you're a visceral you're going
to want that saver it's just plain and simple
anything that clone wars taught me is like
if you're damn bizla you're going to want
that damn dark saber and so having having
a fight between them and yeah it does make
sense to me of it's like they've still been
teasing so much of like what what happened
with the fall of mandalore um under bo katan's
rule because at the end of rebels sabine rent
hands over the dark saber to her but she didn't
as as armor establishes they didn't win it
by creed meaning they didn't win it by finding
it out so i guess there must i like that it
holds that much more credence and weight towards
the fact that one does have to earn possession
of this especially if you are indeed an actual
mandalorian one has to earn possession of
this and uh you know if anyone deserves to
rule mandalore i think it's bokeh town because
she just keeps losing it she's trying to take
it he just keeps trying to unite man and then
every time you catch up with her i was like
oh never mind it's gone what happens someday
because my viewing experience is different
than a lot of people's with star wars it's
like it's a of the animated it's like i watched
mando season one then i watched clone wars
and by the time i watched clone wars the last
season was out whereas on most people watch
clone wars then it got cancelled and then
they watched rebels and then they watched
mandalorian or and or i forget the order and
uh but then the mandel but then clone wars
final season came out um way later by the
when disney plus was out right so i i had
a different experience with it whereas like
captain rex is in star wars rebels so when
i watch star wars clone wars i was like oh
my god is captain rex gonna die but then what
if i had my troubles i would have known that
so basically i'm trying to just i don't know
i'm just giving you guys like my viewing experience
but i i forget names and all that pretty pretty
easily just in general with any show so yeah
just to unpack some of the lore here where
you know we're uncovering everything with
the dark saber and the significance but also
going back to like i like the consequences
of him removing his helmet you know like that's
that because he did it so much in season two
yeah yeah and that being the sort of deciding
factor of like well you guys are pretty evenly
matched and dinjon's got the upper hand on
you and now it just comes down to protocols
yeah yeah now it comes down to how good of
a mandalorian have you been well i like the
way that scene was executed too because when
he's you know being questioned about that
he's just quiet it's like he knows right then
and they're like oh [ __ ] i didn't actually
asked about this and what to do i can't say
anything i guess i'll just not say anything
but then yeah this felt like this just felt
like more pure star wars again like i've been
enjoying book above with that i feel like
i've enjoyed it more than much more than most
people yeah it's like you know online i'm
just like damn some people are really backing
around and uh i've really been enjoying it
a lot um but there is sort of this propellant
almost jumping into hyperspace effect where
when mando shows up or you're like oh god
yeah this is just so much better with him
it feels like there's more natural momentum
you know and i i've really enjoyed seeing
everything we've seen up until this point
with boba fett but i think especially in the
present day like it's clear that you know
this mandalori this dinjarin experience is
happening pretty close to present day for
boba fett at least as of this show and i feel
like up until this point you know most the
flashbacks with boba fett have been what's
really interesting and so now as they meet
up maybe we will get some real momentum in
the present you know well i it weirdly if
anything the the weird part about it is having
this episode in particular especially one
that's solely focused to mando to the point
where i didn't even like care to check in
with boba yeah it kind of highlights some
problems with boba fett the series so far
where i'm like you know i barely even barely
see mando's face like we've only seen it a
few times and i'm like we spend a good amount
of like boba talks a lot more than we probably
expected he's even commented on that he saw
some more horses
yeah he talks about you you see his face a
lot you know it's and and um it's like i'm
just so much more endeared towards him and
to and by the time you get like you you establish
a motive here with with denjar granted we
have two seasons worth of character with him
and like i wasn't instantly attached to danjarin
right away uh like i was drawn to him but
i wasn't like oh you know i'm not gonna cry
over the guy um but here you know it's like
uh crap uh he's stripped of being qualified
as an actual mandalorian and that's what it's
all about he wants to go see grogu like his
motives i'm instantly like really connected
and drawn towards and want to see that journey
so much more than i do care about the actual
why of what boba's doing like it's it's bizarre
because it's somehow i was really invested
in that and now i don't care as much because
of this episode so this is such a strong episode
and yet it also made me go well i don't really
care about the cause of being of that i don't
care what's going to bring them together i
don't really yeah i'm not as invested now
in boba's journey because now i just want
to see this journey well yeah i don't know
i mean there are a million reasons that could
be and i guess here and now i'm sitting here
thinking it's just that personal edge of like
you know him and grogu that connection has
such a gravity surrounding a lot more whereas
yeah like i i think it's fun watching boba
fett set up his ethical crime empire but also
i don't know there's something that doesn't
feel quite as personal about that journey
i guess it feels like a thing an opportunity
that's arisen that boba fett sees the chance
to take whereas this feels like you know there's
you feel how and it's not even a huge part
of the episode but you kind of feel how lonely
he feels without grogu and even that is just
like a little unspoken layer but even now
that he's you know back doing bounties as
usual he's still thinking about the child
he's still propelled there and two checking
in with the mandalorian history and you know
the stuff about like tar viz was a combination
of a mandalorian and a jedi and he's you know
learning the dark saber like that even got
me just like my mind going in a way that some
of the boba fett stuff doesn't get me you
know like poking out into all different avenues
of like where could this go next you know
like it feels a lot more contained and linear
with boba fett whereas dinjarin and two i
mean like boba fett everything is very set
on we're setting up some here on tattooing
whereas like boba dinjaran you know mandalorian
you're always traveling to different places
and you're sort of always on the run which
has a different flavor to it i think just
from the get-go well it's like the boba fett
series is it is kind of a weird paradox with
this episode that i think occurs because the
the boba fett series um what the things i
appreciate about it is that it does it's like
it's primarily on tattooing it's going for
this like you know star wars gangster survived
um it's it's more has more of this gritty
slower paced tone to it sometimes a lot more
meditative especially when you're dealing
with a flashback arena um so i'm that's why
i'm really drawn to it because of because
of all those reasons and i thought with you
know it was reported that ninja would show
up in the show and so i was under the presumption
that this would really highlight the differences
between mandalorian series and the book of
boba fett series and so what they instead
did was they got bryce dallas howard who has
directed two two episodes of the mandalorian
already um each from a season and then she
pretty much did what she pretty much made
a mandalorian episode so it didn't feel like
dinjarin in the book of boba fett world it
just felt like the mandalorian the whole time
yeah yeah you know and um and so i i i was
under the presumption that this would feel
like okay this would really show us with denjar
being in here in with boba as the lead and
maybe that's what the later episodes will
do yeah maybe that's what the progression
will do where it's like you're plucking it
because because tonal wise like just the vibe
of mandalorian in the book of boba fett are
very different from each other so i that so
i don't know if this is actually doing a disservice
to boba fett yeah and that's what i mean where
the paradox might come in is is like this
is just like so much more uh there is more
of an energy to it and even even like the
personality of uh din jar in a lot of ways
just feels a little bit more relatable something
about yeah i don't know what it is and even
just him the actor and i again i really love
tim ware morrison and i love you know what
i don't i guess i've learned not to assume
that it's always the actor in the suit even
though you're tamara morris and you see him
in the suit a lot more uh but yeah there's
just something about the dinjar and body like
he just has such a presence based off his
body language alone and and being with him
and then something i don't know like for as
much as people have complained about the mandalorian
even being like you know a slow-moving show
that's very contained in a lot of ways i still
feel like he brings with him this presence
that just lights up the screen in an interesting
way even when he doesn't have grog because
that was the other thing is you know people
are thinking and i'm sure you know part of
it is they've teased you know he's gonna go
see him at some point you know groggy will
figure back in probably but you know two to
have it be like no he's just back alone it's
still just as intriguing to watch him there
yeah um but i am it does get me excited that
maybe two maybe we will all be on the same
page next week you know i mean given depending
on how he mixes in with the present of boba
fett's story maybe that will be the shot in
the arm some people who haven't been enjoying
the show as much will need you know next week
or something like that uh yeah i mean that's
that's what i'm most interested in with mando
being here is seeing him blend into the world
and what he's like as a supporting character
for the boba fett series yeah because right
now i'm like i could just go for bando season
three yeah i know a lot of love you just shifted
gears and it was just his show uh so that's
that's the one thing is i don't want it to
undercut that because it's still i i have
been enjoying the setup of of book of boba
fett uh quite a lot i'm like we're only four
episodes in guys uh that's what it feels like
now like we're only four episodes in the boba
there's so much more to unpack and and like
mandalorian um was you know fresh and exciting
it was the first star wars show live action
on this caliber uh so there was a lot more
you know like love to behold and were coming
off of films that were being divisive for
a lot of fans so you know i i and it did take
a while to to propel people to the i really
love this show you know it was definitely
faster than what how people have been with
the book of [ __ ] but there's been a lot
of having to separate how great mando is yeah
and then adjust to this new one and that's
not to say some of the filmmaking qualities
or the execution of the writing sure is not
the strongest in certain areas that it can
be i'm not saying those criticisms are invalid
uh i just think that uh you know still needed
some time to really give now that we were
like we're done with the flashbacks let's
focus on the present the first episode of
the president is a pure mandalorian story
which is cool it's like you got the n1 starfighter
moment and i'm wondering it does make me wonder
what the the what they've been doing with
mando and uh because you do kind of pau there's
been like theories forever about grogu and
what his connection is being a jedi lineage
and all that uh he's with luke skywalker and
you know like like we pointed out he had the
thing with a part of the engine of the pot
racing in one episode when he was borrowing
some things he used so we had that and then
here he's getting an n1 starfighter which
would make you pretty it's on tattooing so
you would assume that's anakin's yeah um because
yeah it's not like he was the only one with
that ship i mean he injected in the phantom
menace you know but that like he that is the
ship he uses so it does make me wonder if
they're building because they did so much
like nostalgia for the prequels in this episode
yes like they were the shots were directly
like remember the pod racing yeah yeah yeah
yeah going through the narrow canyons yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i mean maybe i mean
i i you know that's something that marvel
has certainly been doing you know kind of
very focally lately is going back to the things
that not everybody loved and then legitimizing
them in new ways and so i can absolutely see
them mining further from the prequels or for
more of those things to make them feel more
legit and more vital and more worthwhile in
the re-watching because that's also part of
this it's just you get a big canonical you
know revisitation cycle i don't think the
prequels ever had that issue of feeling of
importance yeah they they've always felt super
important and uh and like the level of revere
that dave filoni has for the actual storytelling
like the way he speaks on it makes me go [ __
] maybe i was wrong about feminism he's actually
i think that's why the prequels are are still
so important for star wars fans because whatever
you think of the actual storytelling and filmmaking
yeah whatever story points at hand are still
worthwhile they're still very integral to
the world yeah still very entitled to the
world building whereas some people kind of
feel like with this disney sequel that they're
you know you can't really skip the prequel
yeah those prequels are if you want to get
the world and the lore like there's they're
vital um so yeah i don't know maybe it just
goes to service enhancing the appreciation
for that or maybe they're just doing some
fun stuff like kelly motto getting some of
her back here i actually dated the job was
like it's the most time i feel like we've
actually just spent with her in kind of a
quirkier sense oh yeah like they really allowed
for a little bit more of just let's let's
spend a little bit time with the comedy here
of like mando traveling having to put his
weapons in a sh on a briefcase and then a
lot of hanging out with kelly motto um which
was a lot of fun like amy sedaris is always
great he just dares right yeah yeah she's
always fantastic she bangs jobless
disgusting and it's funny because as much
as this episode did have like a sprawling
or more expansive feel as compared to the
previous couple this also did feel kind of
like i like that we spent our time mostly
with the armorer and and then pelimoto and
it's most of what we're doing you know it's
still pretty contained that but yeah but the
parts that you're spending time with and that
are taking their time you know still feel
like they match the move the story motion
of something like the mandalorian but also
makes sense here well it's like this episode
was so important before dinjarin yes this
is such an important episode for his journey
it's literally the setup of what i i'm assuming
is the setup for mandalore in season three
like this is so so important for him baby
armor that now it's but they also executed
in such a weird way in terms of where to place
this yeah of
it it's like okay for the live-action ahsoka
show you should you should probably watch
the mandalorian episode she's in yes right
you don't have to watch all of mandalorians
season two but you should probably watch the
one choosing the intro yes um and then to
hear that's what they've done with this is
okay it seems like whatever he's dealing with
next like maybe he'll meet up with grogu and
we'll see that maybe that will be just as
important but it sounds like that if you're
someone who's into mandalorian season one
and two but you don't really care to watch
book of boba fett that you'll have to watch
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah this will be canonical
because there's too much important history
yeah i mean because rude is a mandalorian
yeah that's like part of his whole identity
which he has spent so long grappling and they
[ __ ] they actually explained back backstory
because a lot of people watched the mandalorian
didn't watch clone wars or rebels and so you
you know they explained this stuff here and
they don't even explain i was like all of
them they they boil it down on the greatest
wikipedia description ever so uh yeah like
you it's it's so important and it's it's i
don't know it's like as much as i really enjoyed
this episode i'm also fascinated with the
more of the feelings of what this does if
this is actually in service of book of boba
fett or it just makes you go i don't really
care about before this was originally the
season three opener for mandalorian that then
got transplanted into boba fett for some other
reason for the greater grander scope of the
story i mean they would have to have um there's
no way it's like they shot mando season three
and they placed it's just because of the mechanics
of the plot in the episode um it's also really
convenient that he would show up there when
they're just like we need to be muscled yeah
right around the time panic shows back up
he'd happen to
and
i'm assuming he was updated on boba taking
over i guess i mean yeah she just must be
there like we must cut away right before she
gives the big info dump well i mean she he
she says like boba needs help yeah i mean
he just he assumes for boba yeah he assumes
boba so i'm assuming he knows that boba is
now in charge either that or he just assumes
that if i'm seeing fennec i left them two
together so it must be bobo related or something
like gotcha yeah i mean i wouldn't be surprised
if word made it out there because it's not
that far away from where boba is so but then
again to get benefit of the doubt i'm also
wondering if the intention of like the first
four episodes have a very specific tone and
style now we're really shifting gears and
how we're gonna proceed and if like boba and
mando are together and that's like i'm assuming
we'll probably get other mandalorians as well
like okay is the tone really going to take
a shift now for the book of boba fett the
series yeah or is it going to be the same
he's going to kill dinjar and take the dark
saber and re-establish
i'm a true mandalorian now yeah i don't know
i've really been enjoying i've really been
enjoying booger bow with it a lot and uh but
yeah i guess my thing comes down to is like
just didn't feel at all like i was watching
the book of boba fett anymore it was nice
to watch the mandalorian again yeah that's
what it was did you realize i missed how much
i missed the mandalorian and also i guess
i will say to boba fett's credit that it doesn't
just feel like a different version of the
same the mandalorian like it definitely has
its own separate tone and feel to the point
where when you do shift to following dinger
for a whole episode it feels like it's totally
on the show yeah that's why i was saying that
i thought it would be danjarin like what it
would be like to see dinjarn in the world
of book of boba fett next week i said holy
[ __ ] amanda laurie yep which i love i did
love it i did love it i can't complain yeah
all right guys well yeah having it let's just
just wait to see how it goes man guys subscribe
click that bell hit that like button this
was awesome this was an awesome journey i've
really been enjoying this journey a lot absolutely
um but yeah hey mom would do a page
you got 30 seconds shot sar ben israel hebrew
name means storm the gathering storm last
week's boba fett episode title that was about
you sarban israel because you have the power
within you you could be one of the most pivotal
influential people in all of the galaxy and
all you have to do is complete your training
and rise to your mantle you are the true heir
to all the greatness and glory in the universe
serbian israel makes us happy that your hero
with this journey with us and hey keep tight
over there fulfill your greatness and stay
pledged we will always have your back sarban
israel love you buddy happy 2022.